well as ted pointed out the west will be
roasting this holiday weekend just when
we're hoping to stay below 100 due to
those recent monsoon storms temps are
actually climbing yeah and for those who
are working outside you know it's hot
especially when you're out there in the
direct sun mary jane bellissa shares how
companies are trying to protect their
workers
with an excessive heat warning in place
until sunday temperatures are expected
to soar over 110 degrees those working
outside have to take extra precautions
to stay safe and cool
we do this for living
we're not new on this
work hugo bocanegra with unforgettable
coatings and his team are busy painting
apartment buildings 8 to 10 hours a day
they wear light and long fitted clothing
as well as a hat and sunglasses to
protect themselves he's been in this
line of work for more than 20 years so
he's prepared take
two breaks a day
with jig
water like
two or three times per hour
miles reynolds owns sport court las
vegas building pickleball and basketball
courts he worries about his team and
make sure they don't suffer from heat
exhaustion he was kind of you know
fatigued or he was kind of you know just
wasn't very alert and and i think that's
where we have to be careful is just
really paying attention to our bodies
but also looking out for each other as
we're on the job site reynolds starts
the day early to beat the heat watching
each other and and being aware of each
other and knowing when to like really
pace yourself taking more breaks than
normal getting in the shade
you know all those different things are
very big things so as much as we want to
meet meet deadlines we want to really
protect our team if you must work
outside this time take frequent breaks
in shaded areas and drink plenty of
water mary jane belliesa 8 news now
now we should remind you between 2018
and 2021
571 people in nevada died because of
heat exposure so be on the lookout for
some of the symptoms like heat
exhaustion include heavy sweating
extreme fatigue you might feel dizzy
nauseous or even vomiting